[Música]
Bienvenidos a reporteros el magazine de
los grandes reportajes de la reacción de
France 24 soy herminia Fernández
comenzamos
la deforestación es un problema que ha
afectado gravemente en los últimos años
a la selva de la Península de Yucatán
concretamente en la zona de en el Estado
de Campeche la destrucción del bosque
tropical para la siembra masiva de
cultivos como la soya no solamente a
erosionado el suelo causando un Severo
impacto al medio ambiente sino que ha
demostrado que la salud de los
pobladores también ha resultado afectada
por el uso de productos tóxicos
utilizados en la agricultura
industrializada el daño más directo y
evidente es un desequilibrio ecológico
que sufren las especies de abejas que
existen en la zona la función de
polinización se está viendo afectada y
termina golpeando el modo de
subsistencia de los apicultores mayas
hoy nos acompaña Mario carbonell autor
de este reportaje
quería comenzar preguntándole En qué
estado se encuentra en la actualidad la
selva maya
Hola pues Lamentablemente el deterioro
es muy grave basta con tomar un vehículo
dirigirse de la capital de la ciudad de
Campeche hacia hopelchén Y por dónde
quiera que uno voltee es posible Ver
grandes extensiones de Selva talada para
la siembra precisamente de productos
como el mencionadas de la soya pero aquí
en lo más grave Lo más complicado es que
estos suelos ya está contaminados por el
uso de agroquímicos que si bien quizá ya
nos estén usando como el glifosato hay
otros que se han venido utilizando y que
dejan una huella que permanecen en estos
suelos y que incluso pueden penetrar
capas más abajo del suelo contaminando
los mantos freáticos los cuerpos de agua
con lo cual pues es una situación
verdaderamente grave Más allá de todo el
daño que pues provoca a las comunidades
que se dedican a la apicultura que viven
realmente de la selva y que hoy en día
lo que ven alrededor es destrucción
Y qué esfuerzos ha hecho el gobierno
para frenar este problema
bien pues desde el año pasado hubo unas
mesas de diálogo permanente con las
comunidades menonitas y el Gobierno
Federal pues son estas estos grupos que
se han asentado en la Península desde
hace ya casi 40 años los que más
cultivan estas ollas genéticamente
modificada y para ello Pues talan de
acuerdo es precisamente para que frenen
cualquier actividad que pongan riesgo no
solo la selva sino la salud de la
población y en teoría ya no se deberá
usar el glifosato a partir del
Próximamente Pero esto de acuerdo con
los propios comuneros Pues no ha surtido
efecto ellos continúan viendo a su
alrededor que hay fumigación que
continúa la tala estos esfuerzos del
gobierno Parece que pues no han sido
suficientes por lo menos hasta esta
fecha Gracias Mario por acompañarnos
aquí la historia
[Música]
la selva Maya de Campeche es uno de los
principales pulmones del planeta y el
más amenazado en México el Gobierno
Federal lo reconoce en esta región se
pierden
22.805 hectáreas anuales de Selva
Gustavo juchin es apicultor del
municipio de jopelchén relata Cómo esta
gran selva se ha ido perdiendo por la
expansión de la actividad agrícola
industrial
todo este plantío de soya que se debe
aquí y por acá
Todo esto era selva
fue devastado y se plantó la soya y se
sigue cultivando hasta quién sabe cuándo
es una lástima porque aquí habían varios
apiarios todos esos apiarios que estaban
acá fueron desplazados
según el global forestwatch el municipio
de hopelchén perdió en la última década
221.000 hectáreas de cobertura arbórea
Gustavo recuerda el uso que los mayas le
daban a la selva antes de que comenzara
a ser destruida
Sí pues mira que en el bosque la gente
de campo ahí sacaba leña sacaba madera
para sus casas y pues como la mayoría de
nosotros somos apicultores Pues nos
servirá de mucho para que las abejas
pecoreen
y sacáramos cosecha de miel pero ahora
con la soya que está sembrado en vez de
sacar miel se están perdiendo colonias Y
entonces ese patrimonio que hemos venido
dando desde ya tiene siglos se va
desapareciendo poco a poco la
deforestación genera un daño de
múltiples dimensiones como lo explica
Lucero Sánchez bióloga del colegio de la
frontera Sur quien se dedica a estudiar
el impacto que ha tenido este fenómeno
en los suelos de la región esta pérdida
de cobertura forestal que se ocasiona
por la extensión agrícola trae consigo
un efecto negativo tanto a los
pobladores de las comunidades
cercanas como también al medio ambiente
a la calidad del suelo de la diversidad
a la calidad del aire un suelo
contaminado con agrotóxicos conlleva una
cadena de riesgos y son tan dañinos que
aunque se dejen de usar sus huellas no
desaparecen nosotros en el colegio de la
frontera Sur analizamos los residuos que
se encuentran en el suelo en el último
estudio encontramos 24 diferentes
compuestos muchos de ellos ya no se
aplican actualmente pero también tienen
un efecto en la salud humana y en el
suelo por ejemplo estos contaminantes se
pueden de acumular en las plantas que
posteriormente van al consumo humano la
agricultura industrializada incorporó
semillas genéticamente modificadas para
poder esparcir en grandes cantidades el
glifosato una agroquímico al que la soya
transgénica es resistente la
consecuencia ha sido que ese compuesto
tóxico invada los cuerpos de agua y los
cuerpos de los habitantes
el químico Jaime Rendón se ha dedicado
por años a estudiar la presencia de
insecticidas en el ambiente y el
consecuente daño a la salud de la
población de Campeche los resultados son
contundentes aquí en este laboratorio se
procesaron las muestras y se
tienen la evidencia de que hay glifosato
en agua de de en agua subterránea en
agua purificada y en orina de la gente
de de la localidades de coppelchén si
bien el gobierno emitió un decreto para
prohibir el glifosato a partir de 2024 y
especialista Rendón advierte que este
agroquímico es sólo la punta del iceberg
que en el 2024 este ya no se utiliza el
glifosato en México es un logro muy
grande pero entonces va el caso de los
neonicotinoides ahorita prácticamente no
no está en la mirada de los neónico
tinoides pero los neonicotinionios le
están dando en en todo En toda la chapa
a los polinizadores estoy hablando de
las abejas
Rendón habla de un problema que padecen
de manera muy palpable los apicultores
de hoppelchén los daños en su salud
pudieran por ahora no ser visibles pero
la muerte de sus abejas que son su modo
de subsistencia es tangible para ellos
Gustavo Recuerda la vez que lo padeció
se murieron porque el cultivo de la
sandía fue fumigada con insecticidas
altamente
dañinos para las abejas de tal manera
que estas abejas se murieron
fulminantemente no regresaron en las
colonias se murieron ahí en el campo
donde estaba fumigado Sí todo se
murieron el biólogo Erick vides se
dedica a estudiar el daño a las abejas
toma muestras aquí en hopelchén y en su
laboratorio en Chiapas hace análisis del
impacto que tiene la siembra masiva en
las distintas especies eso representa un
problema porque las abejas pues no
solamente son números de especies sino
son su función que es la polinización
Entonces al perder riqueza y abundancia
de abejas también se pierde mucho su
función en el ecosistema y en los
agroecosistemas ante la gravedad de la
problemática que padecen las comunidades
desde hace años comenzaron a actuar para
frenar los daños
Everardo chablé es integrante y Vocero
de la organización mucho cambal y del
colectivo de comunidades mayas de los
yenes evoca el momento en que comenzaron
su estrategia de defensa nosotros a ver
afectado como nuestra forma de trabajo
nuestra forma de cultura empezamos a
organizarnos como como colectivo en su
momento pues se le llamó el mago gm
quemá en mayas no y ogm es organismo
genéticamente modificados no en esa
lucha comunitaria ha sido fundamental la
labor de Lady petch una apicultura Maya
de la localidad de check que saltó a la
fama al liderar una batalla contra el
gigante agroindustrial monsanto su lucha
le llegó hasta la suprema corte de
justicia de la nación donde ganó un
amparo en 2015 para que la trasnacional
no pudiera sembrar más soya transgénica
la defensa de su ecosistema le valió a
Lady page el premio goldman a finales de
2020 el tesón y ahínco que esta mujer le
imprime a su lucha comunitaria se debe a
la entrega total a sus abejas
Entonces yo tengo más de 20 años
trabajando por el rescate y conservación
de estas abejitas
pues una abejita para nosotros en la
cultura maya es una abejita que bueno es
importante y muy valiosa porque
pues tiene mucha parte de una forma
parte de nuestra identidad cultural han
pasado Ya siete años desde aquel triunfo
judicial pero la situación no ha
cambiado la deforestación de la selva la
siembra de transgénicos y el uso
excesivo de agroquímicos Sigue Hoy en
día afectando a las comunidades
nos da una resolución judicial pero pues
no hay nada se sigue haciendo todo todos
es ilegal entonces pues para eso
nosotros no nos ayuda nos sirve y
sentimos de que no solamente es lo que
no se da Esa esa ese seguimiento no hay
estado estas sanciones sino también está
acompañado por la violación sistemática
de los derechos es por ello que de la
batalla legal han pasado a la lucha
comunitaria en la sede del objetivo
Everardo chablé describe Cómo ha sido
este proceso organizativo de la mano de
la asociación mucho mal que pone mucho
énfasis en sensibilizar a los jóvenes en
distintas áreas una de ellas es el
taller de comunicación como el que se
imparte este día
habían áreas de
ganadería
áreas de agroecología juventudes
comunicación y organización entonces
muchos cambal lo que hace es abrazar
este proceso del colectivo
habrás el proceso del colectivo y se
empieza a trabajar con las comunidades
la intención es que conozcan que hay una
alternativa distinta por ejemplo de
trabajar la Tierra sin dañar el ambiente
en el área de agroecología pues se
dedica más como a la parte de Pues sí
desde de rescate de las semillas
criollas elaboración de microorganismos
justo como en esta parte decir pues hay
una alternativa no de trabajo decir pues
no si no vas a fumigar Pero puedes
utilizar algo orgánico que pueda ayudar
como a sustentar esta parte sin embargo
no solo monsanto siembra soya
transgénica de hecho la mayoría de las
hectáreas de Selva taladas son sembradas
por comunidades menonitas que se han
asentado en Campeche desde hace cuatro
décadas hoy los menonitas son vistos con
recelo por los mayas pues les atribuyen
el daño a su ecosistema
en agosto de 2021 el Gobierno Federal
alcanzó un acuerdo histórico con nueve
comunidades menonitas para frenar todas
las actividades que impliquen la
deforestación de zonas de la selva Maya
según los comuneros después de un año
los acuerdos se han quedado en discurso
y los problemas continúan
esos esos acuerdos yo creo que nada más
es mediáticos nada más como para a veces
Mira ya se comprometieron y no pero no
hay un seguimiento
no hay este monitoreo que se requiere
porque no solamente es decirlo sino
también cómo se va a implementar cómo se
va a operar
Cómo se va a llevar a cabo el
procedimiento eso no existe en esta
batalla los comuneros mayas han agotado
las instancias legales y son conscientes
de que solos no van a lograr hacer valer
sus derechos sabemos que la lucha ya no
es lucha solo contra el monsanto es una
lucha contra un sistema contra un modelo
que eso es más allá porque monsanto
entró porque hay un permiso le dieron la
entrada por un gobierno Entonces estamos
enfrentando a una lucha contra un
sistema
opresor despoja quiebra rompe corrompe
los mayas organizados de rechazan el
modelo que se les ha vendido como
desarrollo y se mantienen comprometidos
a seguir la lucha contra lo que
consideran una imposición que ha traído
la destrucción de su territorio
[Música]
hasta aquí la edición de reporteros
recuerde que para sintonizar esta y las
emisiones anteriores puede visitar
nuestro sitio web France 24.com hasta la
próxima